dr anthony fauci says he knows americans
are done with covid restrictions but it
doesn't matter fauci saying folks need
to be ready for them to return because
cases of a new strain of kovitt are on
the rise yeah i'm sure people are are
happy to hear all this let's bring
kentucky republican senator rand paul uh
senator great to have you here and good
to see you
um i i feel like we just teed you up we
know where you stand on dr anthony fauci
you've called for his resignation and
beyond uh does is there any tolerance
for more restrictions if we see cases
rise
well this should come as a shock to no
one that anthony fauci is once again
misunderstanding misinterpreting and
misapplying the data the data is this we
have a lower incidence of covid now than
we've had since the beginning of the
pandemic
lower death rate lower hospitalization
rate and better ability to treat it than
we have during the entire pandemic so
he's just flat out wrong and what we
should be talking about is that if you
do get it or if you're susceptible if
you're in your 80s or 70s and your
spouse gets it there is a treatment but
all of the treatments work best if
you're treated early before your
symptoms get too bad so anthony fauci
won't tell you this but i will the
monoclonal antibodies if you get them in
the first several days are enormously
successful but if you wait they won't
give them to you if you wait until
you're sick enough to go to the hospital
anthony fauci and the government doctors
have dictated
that you cannot get monoclonal
antibodies as an inpatient this is a
real tragedy but there are treatments
and people need to know what the
treatments are but the good news is the
pandemic is on the way
lower incidence lower hospitalizations
lower death rate since the beginning of
the pandemic senator just because many
people out there may not believe that
anthony fauci is talking about this
let's roll the tape back and you can
listen for yourself
i don't think there's much stomach for
people to all of a sudden turn around
even if there is an uptick i think
there's going to be
a lot of inertia if not active pushback
in people if it is required to increase
i'll go back to some of the mitigation
so the advice is proceed with life as
normal as you possibly can
but be prepared that we might need to
make modifications if things change not
much stomach to go back i can imagine
people with pitchforks coming over the
hill
well here's the thing is if you believe
in dr fauci what you should do
immediately is go get stickers and make
sure they're on the floor everywhere you
go so you and a yardstick so you know
that you're six feet away from people
and plexiglas
carry plexiglass around with you because
we dr fauci thinks that plexiglas
somehow you know reflects the virus away
from you none of what he's been for has
worked not one thing he has advocated
other than the vaccine and i'm not
against the vaccine but the interesting
thing is this and he won't admit this to
the public if you take a sample of blood
from a thousand people anywhere in the
united states and you measure to see if
they have antibodies to the virus or
antibodies to the vaccine it's over 95
percent that's why we're doing better
with this we have developed immunity
either from having the disease or from
being vaccinated and that's why we're
doing better in addition to the fact
that the virus has mutated to a less
virulent or less deadly form but he
won't admit it because he's so caught up
in putting stickers on the floor putting
masks on your face putting goggles on
you the guy's a menace and he hasn't
been right really about anything since
the start of this well you always tell
us exactly how you feel senator and i
will tell you that what you're saying is
backed up as far as the restrictions are
concerned is backed up by the latest
johns hopkins university
their meta-analysis used several studies
they said which found locked lockdowns
had little to no impact and reducing
fatalities from kovid during the spring
of 2020
they concluded that the lockdowns were
ill-founded and instead resulted in
enormous economic and social costs where
they have been where they had been
adopted so how is it based on that
science that we can even be considering
this or talking about restrictions even
if this is a worst case scenario and
cases do indeed spike
the reason we're in this situation is
because we've allowed a central planner
dr fauci to be in charge of everything
in a free society everyone's in charge
of their own health care and you go to
doctors until you find a doctor that you
think has an opinion that is valid and
you get your choice so if dr fauci were
a family doctor in peoria he would only
be damaging the people silly enough to
see him as a doctor but because he's
employed by the government and his
dictates go down throughout the system
as he makes errors they're promulgated
everywhere but his biggest error is
pessimism i mean he's already worried
he's shaking and ringing his hands we
know it's coming back and you have to
stay inside shelter in place
there is no evidence of that the
evidence is we're getting better and for
those who do get sick the main thing he
should be telling you which he's not
telling you is there is treatment the
sooner you get the treatment the better
if you are 80 years old your spouse has
covid you can get treatment with no
symptoms and with no positive test
that's how good the treatment is and
that's what they do for people who are
at high risk but he's not telling you
any of that he's just saying oh we need
to vaccinate newborns which is untrue
and not supported by the science they
haven't even taken the mass off the
toddlers here in manhattan new york
there if if if you've got children under
five they are still required to wear a
mask to be in schools and dancing that's
amazing
right the death rate for children under
15 is one in 2.32 million less than one
in a million that's the death rate
there's no reason for any child in
america to be in a mask in sweden they
wore no masks and no children died
senator i want to switch gears quickly
and uh time is growing short here but
you wrote about this so i wanted to ask
you about it the white house continues
to insist that inflation will begin to
mitigate later on this year jerome
powell as he's beginning to raise
interest rates says it's probably going
to take two to three years what's the
inflation outlook to you
well it certainly isn't transitory
anymore i mean they kept telling us it's
transitory to my mind three years is not
transitory but you can't fix inflation
unless you know what causes it inflation
is caused by debt deficit spending and
the federal reserve printing up new
money to buy the debt monetization of
the debt that's where inflation comes
from so the more debt the more inflation
we're paying the bills of six trillion
dollars worth of debt that we had in the
last two years
both parties are responsible for it
republicans and democrats but the answer
isn't adding more debt the answer is
being more fiscally responsible and i
don't know of a democrat in washington
in congress that is promoting any fiscal
debt let me just let me just follow up
on that because i've got my econ panel
coming up and i'll i'll i'll use what
you say now with them
would you be in favor of a paul volcker
style uh addressing of the inflation
situation right now that we saw in the
80s where he tackled it so severely that
there was major economic consequences
short-term interest rates short-term
spiked above 20 percent uh
houses were not selling cars were not
selling but it fixed the problem of the
1970s would you be in favor of that
aggressive approach for j-pal what i
will say is the first thing is don't add
more to your debt so try to balance your
budget or get closer to balance as far
as interest rates i saw a statistic the
other day that i thought was interesting
over the average of the last 50 years
the federal reserve's discount rate has
been a point above inflation right now
it's eight points below inflation so you
have negative interest rates it's sort
of like free money if you got eight
percent inflation you can borrow money
for two or three percent
why not yeah why not just keep borrowing
money so we're in a situation that's
inflationary and as far as when or how
you raise interest rates that's a
technical question and i'm not sure i
have the answer but what i do have the
answer is you should not have interest
rates that are negative and you should
have interest rates that are below
inflation and that's what we have now
all right well we'll be looking forward
to discussing that with the panel coming
up as always great to have you senator
thank you thanks